hey everyone diavalo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over what
exactly
the headless angel or valhalla actually
is the valahella arc is my second
favorite arc in this series just edging
him behind the most recent advent of the
tenjuku vs tomen arc but before we get
into all the meat and potatoes of what
valhalla is
and what the headless angel truly means
make sure that you hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as well as it really helps
out with the algorithm and pushes my
stuff to a bunch of new amazing people
i've also got a membership starting from
one dollar a month if anyone is
interested but anyway enough of that
let's get into valhalla
and it's headless angel so valhalla is
the second major arc in tokyo avengers
behind the moabis arc and is made up of
a variety of different members from the
tokyo magi
gang and moabis the mobis members are
born in 1988 and 1989
and are under the command of one of the
most mysterious characters of the series
shuji hanma hanma is also the vice
leader of valhalla along with tetekasaki
who manages to fool
every member of tomen barbaji and
takamichi into believing he was actually
with tomen
hisaki managed to take all of the
younger members of moabus and added them
to his division at tomen
making the third division the largest by
far totaling one entire third of toman's
actual forces
the other leader of valhalla and
technically its number three was no
other
than kazutora hanamiya who was in charge
of the anti-tomen force
this division of valhalla was created
after kazutora was released from
juvenile prison and consists
of people that he had met while he was
there this division combined with the
older members of moabis which are under
harma's control
calculated up to at least 300 different
members doubling tome and size and with
the thought that kisaki
already has one entire third of tomen's
forces if he was to betray tomin
it would leave them with pretty much a
one to four ratio
meaning that each tomen member would
have to defeat four valhalla members
in a fight valhalla's uniform is a
little more stylized than the tokyo
manji revenge's overalls valhalla would
wear usually any normal clothing with an
ma1
bomber jacket over the top that also has
the words team valhalla
alongside the headless angel on the back
of the jacket there is also some kind of
red ribbon or red tag on the zipper that
is attached to the arm pocket of the
jacket the remaining members of valhalla
that are known
are chome chombo and choji and baji
these four other members are the
remaining division captains of valhalla
chombo and chom both specialise in
fighting and is extremely strong whereas
choji is someone who is more loyal to
kasaki teter than the other two and is
an extremely dirty fighter who won't shy
away from attacking someone who was even
injured bhaji is actually someone who
managed to infiltrate valhalla and
deceive every member of toeman
along with the members of valhalla into
believing that he had actually betrayed
toman and joined kazutora
at valhalla to try and take down the
tomen gang valhalla never had a
confirmed leader due to the fact that
the person who created the gang kisaki
was actually making valhalla so that
maki would eventually become its leader
and he can work as its number two
controlling mikey from the shadows
hence the moniker that was given to the
unknown at the time leader of its group
and its logo which was the headless
angel kisaki believed
that the way to manipulate and control
mikey which was one of his main goals
throughout his life was to create a gang
with a cruel nature that would slowly
start
to bring mikey's dark impulses to the
surface this in turn would enable kasaki
to have complete free reign of the
underworld in japan's delinquent and
criminal society
as no one would be strong enough to
bring down the smart of tedekasaki and
the physical brutality of
sano manjiro in the original timeline
during the bloody halloween incident
valhalla managed to defeat
tomen and the tokyomanji gang was
absorbed into valhalla but instead of it
being completely disbanded kisaki who
was the acting vice leader of valhalla
made mahee the head of its organization
this resulted in the creation of a new
tokyo magi gang that was under the
complete control of valhalla as its
parent organization
though this isn't the past that we've
come to know instead during the bloody
halloween incident due to the
selflessness of bhaji
and the smarts of takamichi this outcome
was slightly different
instead of toman being absorbed into
valhalla it was the other way around and
the remaining members of valhalla
under the command of hanuma were taken
under mikey's control and if you want to
know exactly what happens with bhaji
then be sure to check out my video
on the goat baji kasuki himself but back
to the video
hanuma said that because there was never
an official leader of valhalla they
would join under tomen's banner and
valhalla will now be affiliated with the
tokyo manji gang although this wasn't
the exact outcome that takamichi was
hoping for as it could still result in
kisaki and his cronies being able to
weasel their way into mikey's mind and
try their best to corrupt him but that's
a completely different video for a
different time
for now we're just going over valhalla
some of its members and what the entire
point of its group actually was so to
finalize everything that have gone over
here the creation of valhalla was
something that was made
when both kisaki and hanma took their
respective followings and created a gang
that would eventually be taken over by
mikey
hence the headless angel as the gang
never had any true leader
as kasaki believed he was the shadow to
mikey's light or the moon to his son
in turn this would allow kisaki to
control the japanese underground and
freely do what he wanted while slowly
pushing mikey into darkness
making it easier for him to control
kasaki believed that this plan would
take him two years to become
toman's number two and an additional
three years to take over
all of tokyo creating the largest and
most dangerous delinquent gang of its
time
so that's pretty much everything i could
think of when it comes to what is
valhalla and its headless angel exactly
if you want to keep up to date with the
latest tokyo avengers reviews
spoilers and more content like this then
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
also leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with my content and
pushes it to a bunch of new amazing
people
also i've recently created a membership
option for anyone who is interested in
supporting me for as little as a dollar
a month
if you are interested then be sure to
check out my membership group pacion
below
but anyway enough of that for now it's
been your professional degenerate
diavolo
and i'll see you all in a bit bye
you